densborn nicht irgendwie mitnehmen auch
man die kleinsten echt süß diese gleich
komplett sie kommt einfach so also hallo
tod entschuldigung dass ich nichts über
die lustig macht hallo ich meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren folge hero extra heute
mal wieder so schön alleine weil ich ein
paar pläne hat und zwar soll das eine
sehr produktive folge werden
ich habe wieder ich habe hier meine und
ich habe gar keinen shader drin und zwar
habe ich mir jetzt einen neuen chef ich
weiß nicht ob ich in der letzten folge
schon hatte allerdings habe ich mir
diesen jetzt eingepackt ich habe ich
jetzt mal hier aus klagt weil ich ja von
team und stege wurden wir angegriffen
übrigens entschuldigung geworden als
pussys abgestempelt et cetera kann ich
nachvollziehen
tut mir leid dass ich mich da raus
gelockt habe ich war ja vorher noch im
kampf mit steger allerdings war ich echt
total nichtig wippt ich hatte all diese
basis nicht mehr verzaubert gehabt ich
hatte dieses komische schwerte noch ich
wollte mir noch komplett neue sachen
zusammen kraft und erst dann den krieg
ziehen und es sollte ja ich hab den
stehen shader hatte ich dann noch nicht
drin glaube ich oder hatte ich ihn schon
drin habt ihr ihn schon gesehen weil das
der die sonne viel besser und das ist so
eine viel bessere reflektion und alles
also ich finde ihn jetzt am allerbesten
wäre jetzt drin lassen
vor allem der ist auch bei nacht so
schön wir werden wenn jetzt aufnehmen
werden wer eine nacht mitbekommen
wahrscheinlich damit erstmalig das ganze
über nacht dort sieht jetzt auf jeden
fall hammergeil wo man chocobo ist frage
ich mich allerdings gerade ich verstehe
das nicht ich brauche alle zwei tage
neue schoko- wohl das ist irgendwie mal
tot oder hat im team hat das glaube ich
schon wieder getötet ja ach ja stimmt
die leute meine kommentare geschrieben
dass dem das getötet hat stimmt ich muss
mir die ganze zeit neue chocobos holen
das ist so gott verdammt traurig einfach
nur acht mann legal m
und zwar habe ich mir ein paar sachen ja
mal aufgeschrieben
ich denke mal so durchziehen möchte dies
ein bisschen erzählen möchte
beziehungsweise auch machen möchte und
dass das
dass ich jetzt das schoko nicht mit dem
schoko bochum gehen kann ich versuche
jetzt ebenfalls von den anderen hier zu
holen nämlich daneben wir haben
saalfeld übrigens erst mal noch mal zu
der sache bezüglich höherer position des
connectors saalfeld zweck des connected
einfach blabla
ja das war natürlich pussy haft das gebe
ich zu
allerdings müsse man bedenken wir haben
uns quasi ein babypopo knuffig baby
jacky so ich hoffe mal der hat hier
keinen ohne er hat auf jeden fall keinen
sattel
es lebt nicht gut so peter hab ich sogar
mit einmal bombay gut gut ich brauche
doch ich musste alles geben an die
schwarzen durch alle zombie da brauche
ich dann zum bier dabei dass der mir das
eben umschreibt ich brauche jetzt
allerdings nur ganz kurz das sind ja
alles nur paarung chocobos die hier am
start sind
ich brauche nur ganz kurz eben eins mit
dem ich dann ihr ding sinne hier mit
mercks mich jetzt hallo du vielleicht
keiner hier irgendwie keiner möchte in
vigo saal oder so bombay zombie gehen
alle zombie los
bombay mumbai bombay
kann ich dann nicht irgendwie ihrer
freiheiten oder so ach man das ist doof
dass ich alle meine chocobo ist aber
schön aus hier sieht schön aus
es ist doch dass ihre geburt töten
möchte als auch und schoko nein egal
gibt sich irgendwie schnellere
möglichkeit chocobos um voranzukommen
übrigens hier die blätter nette ideen so
schön ordnete sich schön das war halt so
gedacht wir wollten halt eigentlich hier
dinge sind eigentlich schön stetig
wählen und danach machen wir dann hier
schönes ende und so eine alle zusammen
schädigt auf einmal kommen die draufgabe
töten wir jetzt so ein bisschen lustlos
aber naja es ist natürlich alles legitim
und jetzt an den krieg gegen statt rot
ich werde allerdings ab sonntag kommen
drei folgen mit den wahrscheinlich wenn
das alles klappt nur auf denen das hat
er das letzte mal beim mega geil die
beste aufnahme
die mit denen fand ich deswegen gehen
wir einfach normal auf wir dürfen jetzt
auch die portale von zombies und legal
benutzen also nicht dass er jetzt
irgendwer mal so nach dem motto übrigens
66 ik lizenzen ich brauche noch ein paar
lexika lizenz ich hab ne nachricht
geschrieben beschreibt wie viele ich
brauche nämlich ein paar für die rüstung
die ich mir diese volk machen möchte und
zwar eines ti pharma möchte ich mir
machen zwei okay ich brauche sechs ich
brauch 10.10 essenzen sondern hier bitte
2 lee wir haben so eine ortsgruppe wegen
der stadt deswegen das schreiben heute
machen einen schoko sattelzug op die ja
durch ich schön schlicht und zwar geht
eine frist die westküsten dies gibt
finde ich ist man halt mega schnell mit
und dann wollte ich noch ein legia bogen
machen allerdings in medias bogen
bekommt man doch den kann man sich doch
machen den mach ich mir jetzt erst mal
und zwar brauche ich dann so lustig sind
es bei mir hier ach so ich kann auch
einfach gar nicht schon sehr
was ist denn das für komisches bogen
rezept hier hast du jetzt gleich es
übrigens nacht könnt ihr das mal sehen
erst mal zeigen so strings trink trink
ich habe nur einen string
er wird wohl so sein ne yo yo resources
string china mertens kotten zieht unser
kommen zieht dann nehme ich jetzt mal
einfach knochenmehl kann ich glaube ich
auch gar nicht mitnehmen knochen
das ist blöd dass die ganze sache die
ich machen möchte die ziehen sich so
lange hin weil ich einfach nicht
vorbereitet bin weil ich einfach keine
sachen habe dafür dass er jetzt nicht
ganz das einfach mal hinten jetzt hier
ein anderen vorne ins türlich hier kommt
jetzt einfach hin muss ich eben schnell
ein skelett finden und erkämpft falle
übrigens erst monster dingsbums teil
hier meinte er ist für alle offen
zugänglich also wir dürfen da alle
reihen laufen das ist eigentlich ganz
gut so dass wir halt dann pinocchio auch
man ich möchte zurück ich hatte joe kiki
2.0 ich habe sogar zwei cookies das ist
quasi offen dass wir da einfach so
hinnehmen dürfen leute getöten dürfen
erfahrungen holen dürfen so was alles so
und irgendwann wenn ich mir dann halt
auch noch einen gut da ich schon ein
tipp immer wenn ich mir dann auch noch
eine essenz keeper machen womit ich dann
die ganzen seele in der ganzen mops ihn
einfach einsammeln kann und dann werde
ich mir daraus dann schöne dings machen
schöne wie heißt es denkt beim service
bescheid nicht so vorbereitet wieder wie
sonst was hier richtig gut
daraus werde ich mir dann im meer oder
später weniger früher oder später in
living metal dance sport machen was ich
immer noch geil finden wir schreiben
leute die kommentare das ist doch nicht
so geil sei muss ich gucken übrigens ja
ich weiß dass meine mitarbeit vorbei ist
ich werde noch nicht diese tollen gold
schuhe da machen die bahn jetzt raus kam
jetzt so kommen sieht so kam jetzt kein
string raus muss ihn ja alles abbauen
hö
erkennst ring aus da muss ich sagen wir
rechtzeitig drauf machen oder so was
schafft man da kommen nur kommt raus und
ich bin einfach viel zu doof und das
funktioniert irgendwie doch nicht ich
weiß nicht dann muss jetzt wo liegen die
spinnen finden oder so keine ahnung wo
sind denn hier spinnen richtig wohl in
der höhle schneller und das funktioniert
denn dann haben jetzt gleich gedacht
einfach spinnenweben abbauen hier
erhöhen funktioniert das ganze so mega
gut
richtig stark hier das funktioniert hier
alles hier das ist dass wir zwar noch
ein bisschen ein bisschen doof aber es
ist richtig geil finde ich richtig feuer
bar auf jeden fall dass es ganz sicher
auch in höhlen funktioniert also jetzt
der shader world auf den shader bezogene
dass auf jeden fall richtig gut aber an
die nets habe ich jetzt gar nicht
gedacht da denke ich nie dran da ich
auch bei dem jacko sattel nichts
angedacht dass man ja auch einfach die
netze nehmen kann wo jetzt bin ich
gerade in irgend einem grundstück ich
glaube irgendeiner wollte dahinziehen
glaube ich ich weiß aber nicht ob dieses
tief habe euch welche schon vermissen
irgendwie übrigens ja ich werde die welt
verzaubern of soul oder tiefe sollte
world bringt mir dann dass ich diese
rüstung wenn ich sterbe nicht verlieren
dass die quasi in einem inventar bleibt
da kann ich auch so ein paar waffen war
drauf verzaubern werde ich dann auch in
zukunft machen
denn jetzt werde ich mich allerdings
erst mal mein legia bogen kümmern der
glaube ich zu funktionär ich mach's mal
falsch gibt man daumen hoch wenn ihr
auch immer euren immer bogen falsch
machte minecraft ich mache immer das
erste mal falsch so wartet kann ich auch
benutzte bögen nehmen möchte dass meine
mutter feiert geburtstag ich die dreht
bisschen mucke auf ein tor wieder
strings nehme mein gott
wahrscheinlich heute da so ein bisschen
was im hintergrund ich hoffe man nicht
wir brauchen strings wo kriegen den
strings ja ja ich habe ihnen sogar
mitgeholfen ich bin ja nicht einfach so
vom aufnehmen ich hab ihr
selbstverständlich geholfen ich war
hinter der theke und der wasserski das
auch mit drin und das wasser bewegt sich
und ich weiß ich also richtig geil dank
an luca an der stelle lcc aber nicht
also einen lutetia also wird er
geschrieben
danke an dich loca loca dafür dass du
mir den shader hier gemacht hast ich
finde megageil richtig gut so ich nehme
jetzt einfach mal warte mal werbung hql
dabei aber natürlich wieder mit davon
bei euch übrigens zwei das heißt ich
braucht sechs strings ich habe zurzeit
36 brauche ich weil ich professionell
von den bögen das heißt 9383 zeit
brauchen noch wächst wo sind noch welche
ich finde das ganze macht auch gleich
viel mehr spaß so geil
in der höhle mit shader finde ich es
richtig gut so denn je mehr mit da
hinten die super aber wir haben keinen
fall schaden
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das ganze hier
irgendwie geplant ist von irgendeinem
mitspieler hier von zombie wünsch
unwahrscheinlich denn gerne möchte
gruppen ein
es sieht echt schön aus hier so
irgendwie weise nicht gefällt mir
zuhören mit shader schreibt meine
kommentare wie er das findet oder ob ihr
er sagt zur nähe ohne shader weiter ich
finde es mit shader megageil form sie es
bewegt sich zuletzt zwar kein wind aber
naja so sind da unten noch irgendwie
welche sachen
wahrscheinlich nicht ich auch schon
wieder lava wenn ich vorher resistenz
auf meiner rüstung drauf verzaubert
hätte was bald machen werde ich möchte
erstmal paar levels farmen zwingen
deshalb auch traurig gewesen wenn ich
als gestorben wären im fall wenn ich
wieder ein paar levels habt dann werde
ich auf jeden fall mal verzaubert
sondern beginnt der krieg dann auch mal
irgendwann werden schon so einen spruch
uns ausgeht als zweifacher der wert den
spruch von animusx genommen hatten den
aufstand proben geformte geht irgendwie
wir sind wir sind statt blau
wir sind eine region wir vergessen nicht
wir vergeben wir vergeblich wir
vergessen nicht wir werden kommen
irgendwie sowas zuspruch und den wollte
ich jetzt so bei uns so einführen das
ist quasi unsere taktik gegen die stadt
roth ist gegen tim und stege gegen
stadtrat habe ich an sich nichts so
pantel super nett wie man super nett
aber team und steht ganz einfach
angegriffen und liegt dort richtig doch
wie kriegen auf jeden fall von mir schön
was aufs maul und komme auch auf jeden
fall wenn die christmas kraft gesehen
habt wisst ihr bescheid bzw
die folge kommt glaube ich heute wenn
ihr das diw egal ich brauche man ich
habe jetzt sechs okay was hat eigentlich
geschrieben bezüglich exil sachen das
ist zu viel das ist eine komplette
rüstung was für komplette rüstung das
ist nur zweieinhalb teile sind dass er
es arbeitet er ist dass das sind
zweieinhalb teile
guck mal hier was ich für eine killer
hülle hat abi abi bei mein abi habe
hoffentlich also wenn man es schafft man
eigentlich schon doof dadurch zu fall
kommt mir vor mir sitzen
durchgefallen weil er den termin
verpennt hat becker nicht gehört dann
ist man automatisch durchgefallen
ob er auch richtig gut von ihm ich
brauche reisen reisen und bögen also
habe ich nicht
1 23 13 so und jetzt die bögen wollte
nur mal das string bogen 1 2 1 2 1 2
bogen reisen so einen rückbau aber ich
hoffe mal das geht mit dem wir das für
richtig
nein es geht nicht ich habe dir doch
gerade erst angebrochen den bogen auch
mal
gegen den flüchtigen habe ich gar keinen
vernünftigen bogen richtig scheiße
herkommen hier zählt nochmals man jetzt
muss ich noch mal so einen bogen machen
ist das ähnlich es hat wirklich immer
diesen kleinen sachen an diesem kleinen
verschiedenen sachen aber dass so auch
jetzt fehlt noch wieder das training
etwas extremes auch kaka wäre ich noch
mops neese wahrscheinlich schon tot
doch die leben noch ist er total
abgedunkelter galopp glock ging es etwas
passieren die verrückten hier den boden
fallen lassen
wo sind meine strings hey hey hey ich
hab mir noch keinen bogen gemacht
oder habe ich mitgemacht ich weiß es gar
nicht gerade einen bogen gemacht stopp
dass man eben wieder ganz kurz hier habe
ich mir in bogen gemacht ja fall halt
runter zurück meine goldene feder ist
kaputt aber die ist wieder da ich habe
mir keinen bogen macht starb jetzt hier
einfach am boden
aber obwohl meine streams habe ich den
weg gelegt ich weiß nich normann ich
brauche es dringend ich gucke jetzt also
kämpfen hatte ja erst hier die schmiede
da kann man sich nehmen was man will
an waffen krams et cetera goldene
karotte mögen da sind bögen drin auch
ich blöd man kristall bogen sehr gut
stellt ob der gut da schaue ich gefragt
erschießen - 12h der sogar recht gut
eigentlich bekämpfen meinte der star
wings geltende trainer wo wo es
irgendwie sonst so ein geiles klettern
ich sehe gar keine ganz so was hat er
denn fallen lassen fünf schwert was ist
das
das wort habe ich schon aber lässt
einfach mal vor allem möchte ich gut
jetzt habe ich auf jeden fall bogen
scheiße ich möchte aber in medias bogen
den finde irgendwie viel geiler
ich wollte diese erfolge so viel
schaffen und jetzt da phoenix von kef
nehmen und jetzt bin ich hier
man oh schade möchte ich spinnen kann
ich auch nicht mehr sehen jetzt
irgendwie ne ich möchte jetzt noch ganz
schnell in die höhle
eben kurz dann kurz also der hier war
ich ja schon ich möchte wenigstens noch
den bogen fertig kriegen in dieser folge
ist kann ich ja gar nichts erreicht
schnee sieht übrigens auch mega weniger
los mit dem shader mag das irgendwie
nicht so crazy daisy davos ist damit
geologe macht mist anhören sein oder
polen
da ist das was ich brauche
doch irgendwas hier so
hey bist du denn bruder pizza das ende
wird hier der kleine zauberstäbe auch
wie knuffig oma das sonst borna von den
bass los doch diese hielt stäbe jetzt 40
mal hier
kennen wir den sportlern ich irgendwie
mit nimmt man die kleinen sind echt süß
diese gleich komplett sie kommen einfach
so an so hallo tot
tschuldigung dass ich mich sogar die
lustig mache aber nur witzig die möchte
er sitzt versucht bilder hör auf damit
hey wo kommen die alle her ab das bonner
hier bei den bonn jetzt eben einer ab
essen einfach nur essen auf jeden fall
richtig gut
neo das ganze wasser wird jetzt hier auf
die jungs ich brauche jetzt hier
irgendwie seite und china ihre katze
wittmann haben die nicht irgendwie
strings in ihren kisten machen das wäre
sogar schönes produktives was da drin
hätten euch bloß essen hier angst dass
hier untergeht und die geht es runter
ach man ich vermisse dich jetzt kann er
nicht sein hier jetzt endlich strings
oder
auch nix drin kassel nur essen einfach
ja massaker richtig richtig gut was
bringt diese leuchtenden pilze als ich
weiß auch nicht was hier bringen ja die
sachen da sind irgendwie zu weit unten
was bringt hast dich schreibt mir das
alles in die kommentare hätten ihn
einfach so was ist das denn
diese welt ist geil enchanted book
vetter vor links oben das sieht schön
aus dass sie echt schön aus irgend
welche schuhe drauf machen wollen sie
erst jetzt bräuchte ich ne willst du das
jetzt bräuchte einfach so einen schönen
dingsbums electric staff womit man
electric star womit man fliegen kann
halt aber nein ich bin noch nicht
sondern verbreiten vielleicht wollt mir
denen auch sowas geht meistens nicht ich
versuche ihn zu überreden das haben wir
so was gibt weil ohne den würde ich halt
aus öl nicht rauskommen und das werde
ich viel geiler dann bis zur beseitigung
nicht runterfallen
muss ich da hingehe rauskommt ich glaube
das reicht nicht mal meine ganzen
komische steinchen die ich war doch
reicht sogar mehr als genug so ich erst
mal eben das was da rausgeholt habe ich
finde dich sooo geil aus diesem winter
region
diese winter region mit mit dem shader
ist echt einfach nur so geil dass an
ich mache ich nichts anderes außer
screenshot welt sogar losziehen so hier
muss auch jetzt in wie ich will auch
nicht runter weil ich weiß dass da
wieder rauskommen wie die beats war es
noch so jetpack wir sind dann überziehen
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat und
die mehr von solchen folgen sehen wollt
wo ich versuche ein bisschen produktiv
zu sein ich habe einen mann gesehen ich
dir schon mal runter vom server dann
lass einfach eine bewertung darüber
würde ich mich auf jeden fall freuen und
dann würde ich sagen vielleicht beim
nächsten mal wieder
morgen am samstag noch allein am sonntag
damit den und dann tschüss